Ben Schwarz Real world connectivity - Beyond
the bubble
>> One did my favourite things about both
JSConf and CSSConf is this warm and fuzzy
feeling you get when you come here, like a
family reunion without the bad parts!
I love that.
I've been coming for I think four years, and
every single time, it is even more amazing,
and more people are getting into this nice
family of ours.
Ben is a really good example of that.
He not only runs JSConf back in Australia,
but he's been coming here for three or four
years.
He mc'ed two of them, and now he's speaking
so it comes around.
You can end up attending and then speaking,
which is really great.
You can be on the stage.
Yes, Ben is from Melbourne in Australia which
is a great city.
I lived there, too.
He's a founder of Calibre which is a web-performance
monitoring tool and he will tell you about
the state of connectivity, the state of the
internet and what we can do for people to
make the internet and web faster for them.
Please give a really washing welcome to Ben
Schwarz.
[Applause].
BEN: Hello!
How are we doing?
Doing good?
My mother doesn't know what I do, so this
isn't going to help her, but if everyone can
just yell "ya" as I come around, okay?
AUDIENCE: Ya.
BEN: Mum ... I don't know!
[Laughter].
That was fun.
My name is Ben Schwarz.
I'm from Melbourne, Australia.
I've been coming here for a few years and
it's my favourite conference anywhere in the
world to come.
It is a huge privilege.
Thanks for everyone for making it great for
me to be here.
My talk today is called "Beyond the Bubble"
and I hope to achieve, to give you some context
that maybe you haven't maybe necessarily considered
as part of your day jobs.
When we usually talk about performance, we
talk about how quickly pages load, we talk
about how much money Amazon made when they
made something half a second faster, but often,
that's kind of really as far as we go, I think
is really sad because performance is a pillar
of user experience, and yet every aspect of
performance work we are doing right now seems
to be a bit of an afterthought.
Sites are often deployed to production, and
then we say all right, let's see how this
performance.
And if the result are disappointing, then
maybe do our best to see what we can do.
But often we have to just move on because
there isn't the time and budget, and nobody
is really committed to it by that point.
And we are still, when we're doing this, when
we're building the sites and apps and these
experiences, we are doing doing using a $3,000
dollar computer or a $1,000 phone and you're
doing it on localhost.
Of course it is going to be fast.
I think it is our -- doing it on localhost.
I am the founder of a company called Calibre,
a recently young company.
It is so young, in fact, that I'm the only
person in the company.
I do everything.
What that really means is I'm full-time now.
I became full-time in January, and ultimately,
that means that every day, I am helping to
build tools to make the web faster, or helping
to try to contribute to that, or I'm doing
audits for people, or I'm diving in stack
traces.
I'm kind of doing that performance work that
you would maybe do if you had the time, but
that's all I'm doing right now.
I hope through that you will maybe enjoy the
talk ahead.
So, I thought it would be really interesting
look at somewhere where time really equalled
money, and in the last 30 years, we've been
trying to reduce latency between locations,
but somewhere it was really hyperfocused was
in the stock changes between Chicago and New
York.
Every few milliseconds you save or make literally
billions of dollars.
In the made 1980s, the round-trip latency
was 14 and a half milliseconds, cut by a millisecond
and a half in 2010 by shortening the physical
fibre route they took.
They thought this is too slow and we will
do something else.
[Sound cut] you see that large tower there.
That's a microwave tower.
These towers - using these towers, they were
able to get that connection speed right down
to 4.2 milliseconds which is a huge improvements,
three times over where we started in the 1980s.
Interestingly enough, when these towers were
constructed, they were buying up little plots
of farmland and between, and I think some
of these towers they actually had to pay these
farmers - in the regions of $500 million just
to put a tower there.
I think that's particularly interesting because
I think when we are building sites and apps
and throwing them in a browser and we are
delivering this HTML, right, and, as you saw
in the previous talk, we are getting better
at detecting the resources on the page and
pre-getting them, but up to now, what we've
been doing is this: we're just throwing things
at the customer.
Saying take it all, I don't care about you.
Whether on a tiny phone with a slow CPU, or
maybe you've used all your data plan, like
I have in Berlin already in a week, we're
not doing enough here.
I'm going to take you through some stats about
the state of global connectivity.
Right now, there are 7.4 billion people on
the planet.
46 per cent of them have access to the internet.
That means that we are actually at a point
where there are four billion people who don't
have any access to the internet at all.
We're only halfway there.
We're not even halfway there yet.
So why don't we have an a look at how quickly
the internet is growing, and if you were thinking
maybe Europe is getting better connectivity,
maybe it's US, 300 million people there, may
be it is in Australia where I'm from, and
really trying to build a faster internet,
but struggling, it isn't really sort of in
that bubble that we are in right now today.
If you look at India just last year, their
internet users grew by 108 million people,
which, in case you were wondering, that's
more than the population of Germany.
This is 30 per cent year on year from the
year previously.
If those numbers are matched again this year,
that will be 140 million people.
Airtel, who are the largest carrier, have
255 million customers, people who just have
a phone plan, and this stat, the last time
I researched it, it's gone up by 5 million
subscribers, and their share has fallen from
32 per cent of the marketplace.
Truly, truly incredible numbers.
In India only 635 per cent 1.2 billion don't
have access to the internet, so that means
that's 864 million people who are yet to get
the internet.
They're about to.
That's essential lit population of China again.
I took time to look at what data costs in
different locations.
The way that I came up with these numbers
here is I took a pre-paid plan, which is usually
cheaper than a post-paid plan, and I took
the minimum wage of these countries, and I
calculated how many hours would you have to
work just to get 500megs of data.
In India, it is it is 17 hours, but in Germany,
it is less than one hour.
Our, let's call it, data addiction isn't met
with the same enthusiasm in other places in
the world.
Could I get some water?
Thank you.
That could be one hour for eight songs on
Spotify, six minutes of YouTube, and less
than an hour playing games.
Or you can go to the Burj, empty your cache
and hit reload 28 times.
Even if you can afford the internet, you're
not necessarily going to get fast internet
all the time.
Back in Melbourne last year, I lived on the
wrong side of the street to get cable connection
so I ended up having DSL and it was a lot
slower than it should have been.
Even if you have LTE advertise the on your
phone, you may not get the same LTE speeds.
In Singapore, the average is capping out at
about 50 which is super great, but in India,
it is doing 6.39Mbit/s.
It's no matter where you are in the world.
I had a look at the German internet plans
because I'm Australian, and it's very different
here.
I Shaw that there are 400 Mbit connections.
Over the year if it worked out to EUR30 a
month.
Put that on a global scale, does anyone want
to guess where the global average for connection
speed would be?
Shout out numbers?
Two?
50?
50.
Okay.
It is actually seven.
This is the global average.
So this is, it is pulled down by some places
and pulled up by others.
I thought maybe we could look at the mobile
speed.
In Canada, which is covering the Americas
region, the best average, or the highest average
speed is 10.3.
In Australia, for Asia-Pacific, 13.
For the United Kingdom, Europe, it was 26.8
- [Laughter] - and the UAE for the Middle
East and Africa region was 17.2.
But it goes further than that.
60 per cent of all but global mobile connections
are actually 2G.
So we know that, even if you do have LTE,
you can't really assume it's going to be fast.
On average, we're only doing 7Mbit a second.
Let's look at devices.
Most devices on the web are handsets.
This has been the case since 2014.
I thought maybe I would have a look.
I have an iPhone in my pocket, and I'm sure
a lot of you do too, and maybe use an android,
and that is cool too.
Have you thought of devices that people use
in other locations?
Here are the top five devices for three regions.
China had three phones I had never heard of,
and they were selling enough devices to cover
the population of my country multiple times
over a year, so that's reasonably significant.
The I don't know hands in India is corresponding
to its very mixed market but it is a big collection
of devices.
So, I got to wondering, is there a single
device that best represents average?
If we need to - we know that these devices
are super, super different.
How do we test this and understand what to
do next?
Thanks to our friends at Google, there's been
some research done into this.
At the moment today, if you were to take a
fairly average phone, it is not super expensive,
I think in Germany, it is EUR180 if you were
to go and buy one won you would end up with
a quad core CPU, decent amount of storage.
This isn't the slow phone that people will
tell you in talks you have to think about
these other people, this is a pretty middle-of-the-road
phobe.
It is not the fastest and it is not the slowest.
If you average out global devices, this is
where you will end up.
Has really great.
You can test them on web page tests, and they
have these devices in data centres around
the world.
Let's say you didn't have access to a device.
Here's what you can do.
Go into your current dev tools.
Click on the timeline.
Click on "capture settings" CPU, drag it down
to 5.
I know 5 is seemingly an abstract number,
but if you're on a recent Macbook Pro, you
will end up with the speed of about a MotoG4.
There's been research done into this, and
you can calibrate your device, but if you're
looking for a close enough experience, that's
where you should end up.
5x slowdown.
What is clear after we've looked at connectivity
and devises is there aren't any context.
If you go for a proper average, it changes
daily.
I like to think that there are two versions
of the internet.
There's the one that we use - us - and then
there's one that we usually don't.
I've been experiencing a little bit of the
column B in the last couple of weeks here
in Germany, and the aeroplane Wi-Fi I think
at times was better than the Airbnb I have
at the moment.
The conference Wi-Fi hasn't been too bad - thanks
for doing OK on that, JSConf - and Lie-fi
when it says you're on Wi-Fi and nothing happens.
We know that the connections vary and it might
be that because you're at the wrong end of
the building, and too many brick walls, or
for whatever fucking reason, your modem needs
restarting again.
It happens, I understand.
One thing is clear, we need to stop optimising
for $3,000 computer with fast connections.
Inconsistency is a major property of the web
in general, but now that we are understanding
that we are in a global landscape, it is time
that we started by about what we are delivering
to people so we should gather knowledge and
build with more understanding and empty.
Looking beyond the delivery of an asset or
looking how an asset is put down on to a device,
we are generally looking at three things:
delivery, so this is the time where we are
saying how many scripts are there on this
page?
How big are they?
What do they look like?
There is the pass cycle.
This is when the browser gets those assets,
and it has to figure out something.
Maybe it has to decompress the G zip on a
resource, maybe it has to parse and compile
the JavaScript, maybe it has to get an image
and then composite it before it actually paints
it.
The last part of that is run time.
These three phases of performance that we
should worry about.
Runtime is actually the actual run time that
we are giving smooth, fluid animations and
making it responsive to a user input.
But unfortunately at the moment, the one rear
really forgetting this is parse time.
We're throwing down scripts at the browser
and we're just hoping for the best.
This wonderful graphic is taken from a brilliant
blog post called JavaScript start-up time
and a rough how V8 works or more like, the
V8 people tell me, how it will work really
soon.
This varies from engine to engine, but they
take your JS, they generate byte code, do
optimisation stuff, and then they build it
for your architecture.
When you're taking the 410 average script
size, this is the average across the web,
right?
This is what we are on average setting.
There's been the argument that maybe we can
reduce that size, just remove a jpeg - I won't
name names - but this became a bit of a popular
thing to say a couple of years ago, but I
tell you why it's wrong.
Forget 410kb.
When you decompress, it could be three to
four megabytes.
It is the three to four megabytes that your
phone has to understand, compile.
I took the JSConf site which is really light,
whoever worked on it didn't have to do much
stuff to make a pretty website to tell you
about the conference - it only had 57KB-of-scripts,
jQuery, some web stats and a tiny 1kb.
When I bench marked it on desktop, this one,
and a MotoG4, I found that the script time,
all I'm dealing is loading the page, and we
are spending three times the amount of time
just in scripting.
Why is that important?
It is important because this is happening
in the JavaScript main thread.
This is also blogging Paint, and in these
are all the little things that make your website
feel when you're also contending with web
fonts loading, and disappearing, and a different
one appears, and a user is controlling, and
then an image loads and then that pops back
up - you've all even is, right?
We are suspect to it.
I look the Lufthansa site this this is the
mobile site.
This is probably reasonably optimised.
On average, a little bit bigger than other
stuff.
And it actually compressed really, really
well, and, again, well, it was double.
It doesn't mean that these numbers are completely
linear.
You can't say that it's going to be 600kB.
You do need to test that stuff.
I did start testing.
Let's do an experiment here.
Maybe I can just say, "Delete all of your
JavaScript".
You might not like that be.
So I took the Guardian's website.
They've done some fantastic work.
Patrick Hammond who is here spoke two years
ago at CSSConf, and he showed all the really
great work he's done at the Guardian.
I don't want to bash it up too much, but I'm
going to show you something.
This is the Guardian loading side by side.
On the left, we have it without JavaScript
and on the right, we have it with.
The version on the left was completely visible
in under 5 seconds on a 3G connection - bang,
done.
The other side: well, there is the fonts,
switching, loading.
The weather appeared and then a related article
appeared at the bottom of the screen and it
stopped rendering somewhere around the 22-second
mark.
Unfortunately, the 22-second mark is about
the average.
The average for this is about 17 seconds.
This is not a bad website.
This is very, very normal.
It goes further too.
Of the difference between the requests, and
it wasn't all JavaScript, it was images and
assets and other stuff, we, with JavaScript,
it was 3.4 megabytes, 115 requests, otherwise
1.59 and 61 requests.
I think that's a lot just to show people a
related article and whether and different
[sound cut] but we didn't really improve it.
We talk about progressive enhancement [sound
cut] one thing that I've really noticed this
that the metrics we're currently - I think
they are the important part.
Metrics like unload, on DOM-content loaded
which is everything ready, DOM ready, and
speed index which is my particular favourite
to have a little go at.
I know people who put "MS" after it so that
is looks ... good metrics try to aim something.
Here are some examples of good metrics.
Has 19 heard of them?
Any of them, all of them?
I'm going to explain a little bit about what
they are.
The user navigates.
We have a first paint.
The first paint is when we see anything a
wide screen.
We go on, render a little bit more.
Then we have some more graphic starting to
appear, the font hasn't uploaded yet, and
then we get to a point where we get the meaningful
paint.
That means that the text is visible, somebody
did see something readable approximately visually
complete means when the area in the view port
is fully resolved, let's call it.
That's great.
Visually complete is a difficult one.
It is not something that you do get out of
dev tools, so how can we produce these metrics
and actually get something out of it.
Thankfully, there's a tool called Lighthouse
built by the Google Chrome team which comes
as a browser extension.
And you can just go to a website, click on
it, generate a report.
It loads the site by default in nexus 5x,
I think, and it slows the CPU down, it checks
it in an offline mode, it will give you some
stats with how it's performing as a progressive
web app, accessibility stuff request and best
practices.
That's really great.
I have a little secret though: can we keep
this between us?
Yes.
As of Thursday, Lighthouse dropped into Google
Chrome can nary.
I will show you how to get this now.
You need the latest Chrome Canary and animate,
I imagine.
You need to go to the chrome Flags page, search
for dev tools experiments and turn that on.
Then relaunch your browser - this is quite
a step.
Go to the thing that you want, and pop up
your dev tools, go to the settings down here,
over to the experiments, you don't see it,
right?
See how it appeared.
You have to hit shift.
It's a little secret.
Then they appear, all those things that you
didn't know were there.
Then you have to turn it on.
Close it.
Open it again, and audits two will appear.
Then you get a lighthouse button and you can
choose the audits that you want to do and
you will get some idea of the performance
of your browser.
I'm not sure when this is going to reach stable
but they're working hard on it Google IOs
in a week and a half and the guys have been
worked really, really half.
First meaningful paint, visually complete.
I'm going to talk to you about a what this
other metric we've heard a little bit about
is.
It is time to visually complete.
This is how they're calculating it now in
lighthouse.
I think it is really, really cool.
We watch the timeline and we figure out when
the browser is visually complete, and then
we are watching the JavaScript main thread,and
we're watching the sub tasks that are happening,
looking for them that are shorter than 50
milliseconds.
We figure out when there is a five-second
window without a long Taft, task.
The reason we do that because time to interactive
is a really good way of getting that empathy
for a user that it's not popping around the
web fonts nor and it's not jumping up and
down and going all over the place.
Your target for every device, and I'm talking
about the phones in your pockets is to get
it in under five seconds.
Even better come up with the Twitter team
do having a metric of time to first Tweet.
They've been doing it for years.
Trying to find ways of understanding how your
users are using your apps and sites and get
a metric and track it.
Because it doesn't matter when unload happens.
It is totally irrelevant.
Don't try and keep people on your side for
as long as possible.
Help them get to their goals and do it quickly
so they can do something else which is far
better.
I know that the performance landscape is realising
fast and so many bits and pieces to worry
about.
My advice is to pick one or two and give them
a shot.
All of these things that are on the screen
here, using a CDN, like weapon P, the purple
pattern, all of these will improve website
performance, give one of them a go, test it,
measure it and improve.
If you're wondering where I got the stats
from, they are from the State of the Internet
report?
Has anyone seen this before?
Like ten people, I think.
It is a quarterly report put out, so, all
my data is from Q42016, and it is just a pdf
report.
You can see what the global averages are.
The global average for connection speed went
from 62M/bit per second to the 7.
We are improving but it is very slow.
We've been focused on the wealthy Western
web for so long, we're building for the machines
we're using, but that's bullshit.
We didn't sign up for that.
We signed up for the World Wide Web.
I want to encourage you to make the web faster,
everyone.
That's what I'm trying to do at Calibre, and
that's what I'm dedicating all my work to
at the moment.
Hopefully, you can get Calibre, give it a
shot.
If you don't, try Lighthouse, that's great.
Otherwise, if you want stickers, come and
see me or something.
It will be cool.
Thanks a lot.
[Applause].
>> You have literally 60 seconds to get coffee
or snacks.
Run!
Are we ready?
We're really not ready!